اشتهر مصطلح صناعه الموت في معجم الاسلام
السياسي بالدرجه التي شعاع فيها انه مصطلح
اصيل لدى جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
وتفرعاتها خاصه انه اخذ زخمه وشرعيته من
تبني مؤسس جماعه الاخوان حسن البنا له لكن
يبدو ان الحقيقه غير ذلك وان مصطلح صناعه
الموت مستعار الى شان التخفيف ومسروقا الى
شئنا غير ذلك من سياق القومي بعيد كل
البعد عن تنظيرات حسن البنا الاسلاميه ولا
تقل عنه تطرفا وردليه لكن بعيد الولوجيه
مختلفه في المدرسه الثانويه المركزيه
ببغداد خريف في سنه
1933 خاطب سامي شوكت الداعي السياسي
القومي العروبي الطلاب في محاضره بعنوان
صناعه موت قائلا لهم ان المال والعلم ليس
الكل في استقلال الامم وليس المعول الوحيد
الذي تهدم به اسوار الاستعمار وان القوه
في رايه هي التربه التي تنبت عليها بذره
الحق ومعنى القوه هنا صناعه الموت رفع
سامي شوكت ما توجهه العسكري القومي شعار
خاشقجي فان اعترف يزيل النعم واصل امرا
بتعليق الشعار في كل المدارس بعد سنوات
انتحل حسن البنا ذات المصطلح صناعه الموت
ليلبسه هذه المره ثوبالايا هناك من ذهب
الى ان استخدام البن الاول للمصطلح كان في
العام
1934 وروايات اخرى رجحت ان الاستخدام
الاول كان في العام
1938 وهو تاريخ نشر كلمه حسن البنا بعنوان
صناعه الموت بجريده النذير التابعه لجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وجاء فيها اجل صناعه
الموت فالموت صناعه من الصناعات من الناس
من يحسنها فيعرف كيف يموت الموتى الكريم
وكيف يختار لموتته الميدان الميدان الشريف
والوقت المناسب فيبيع القطره من دمه باغلى
اسنانه ازداد زخم استخدام المصطلح من قبل
حركه الاسلاميه في مطلع السبعينيات
الميلاديه في مصر حتى اصبح احتراجه الخطاب
الاسلامي الاصولي الراديكالي مع الحرب
الافغانيه السوفياتيه على يد الاب الروحي
للمقاتلين الافغاني العربي الفلسطيني
القطبيه عبد الله عزام ثم استخدام القيادي
السعودي الصحاوي سلمان العوده لهذا
المصطلح في محاضره حمل ذات العنوان صناعه
الموت في مطلع التسعينيات استخدام القومي
سامي شوكت لهذا المصطلح جاء بعد ان اعطيت
قوميه العربيه والوحده العربيه مضمونا
ثوريا عسكريا بدا بنظام الكشافه الذي
انشاء الذي انشاء ساطع رائد الحركه
القوميه العربيه ومدير المعارف في العراق
حينها لتنتقل مع سامي شوكت الى ابعاد
الاكثر راديكاليه تاثرا مباشرا بالتنظيمين
النازي الالماني والفاشي الايطالي فصدره
في العراق في العام
1935 نظام الفتوه التي وضعها سامي شوكت
الذي كان مديرا للمعارف ثم وزير لها بديلا
عن نظام الكشاف بهدف تعويض الطلاب على
خشونه العيش وتحمل المشاق وتدريبي بهم على
التمارين العسكريه واقرت وزاره المعارف
دخل منهج التدريب العسكري في المرحله
المتوسطه والثانويه
وتشكلت هيئه لتدريب الطلاب عسكريا
والسحدثت رتبه فتى اول للمتفوقين عسكريا
معتمده زيا وشعارات مخصصه فمن اي المدارس
استلامت التيارات القوميه فكره مهمه الموت
هذه وكيف حور كلا من التيارين
الراديكاليين الاسلامي والقومي التنظير
الاستشهادي وبتعبئه عاطفيه غير علميه ولا
واقعيه لتدخل على احداث التاريخ بهذا
النفس الاستشهاد والانتحار وهل استلم حسن
البنا صناعه الموت من سامي شوكت ام اخذها
من الشبان اصحاب القمصان الزرقاء في مصر
انا هدى الصالح وهذا برنامج جماعه في
الجزء الاول من حلقتنا عن صناعه الموت
ومؤسس هذا المفهوم سامي شوكت ابن يستضيف
معنا الباحث والمؤرخ العراقي الدكتور سيار
الجميل حياك الله دكتور وسامحنا ان احنا
صحيناك بدري معنا لفريق التوقيت بيننا
وبين كندا وحتى ان الشمس غابت من خلفي
خلافه للعاده ان احنا بيكون وقتنا نهاري
يعطيك الف عافيه دكتور من
مذكرات سامي شوكت همم بيقول عن صناعه
الموت في سنه 1933 جمعت مديري المدارس
ومدرسيها والقيت فيهم كلمه طويله اعلنت
فيها ادخال الدروس العسكريه في مناهج
المعارف التربيه في مناهج المعارف وتطرقت
الى معنى الغرور القومي وضروره معرفه
صناعه الموت وضربت عدد من الامثله على بعض
الشعوب التي تستطيع الحصول على الاستقلال
وحرمت من الحريه لانها لم تتقن صناعه
الموت
اه طبعا الى اخره من هنا دكتور ابغى اسالك
امم
شل يعني
جذور هذا المصطلح همم يعني من فين بدات
تكوين يعني او بروز هذا المصطلح وكيف ظهر
في اا في العراق
لم يكن هناك مصطلح شبيه له في اي مكان قبل
هذا التاريخ لكن الفكره اصلا همم
ماخوذه همم من همم المساده في الثلاثينات
في همم في اوروبا وخصوصا
همم البرشا فيك والمنشفيك واصولا الى
نازيه هتلر
وايضا تشوف همم
ايطاليا يعني
ممثلين
يعني هذا الفكر
المرحله لكن مصطلح صناعه الموت هو عراقي
بامتياز ومن خلال همم سامي شوكت همم
طبيب العسكري الذي ولد
1895 94
ووووو ودرس في اسطنبول يعني بدايات هذا
الرجل لم تكن همم
تطلع عليها مثل هذه الافكار او مثل هذا
المصطلح لكن بعد
الموجات التي ظهرت في الثلاثينات وخصوصا
في الثلاثينات همم
السحلف هذا المصطلح وعمامه وقد اختلف معه
العراقي يعني
اختلف معه همم السيد محمد رضا الشبيبي
يختلف معه اختلف معه اخرون اسمح لي اذا
قطعتك بما انك ذكرت اسم ال همم الحصري او
خلافه همم اختلاف مع سامي شوكت في هذا رغم
ان ساطع الحصري كان ايضا عند موضوع عسكره
الشباب او سكرت المدنيين ودعا الى
القوه ساطع الحصري
اسس الكشافه في العراق
وعندما جاءت فكره الفتوه من خلال سامي
شوكت همم اختلف معه ولم يوافق سامي شوكت
على هذه باعتبار على اساس انه الفتوه تحل
محل الكشاف فاختلف معه شاطئ كون الكشافه
تحوي
اولاد وبنات
وان الفتوه فقط مقصوره على الذكور
وقال بانه الكشاف النظام عالمي
الفتوه وهي ماخوذه من التراث العربي
فلم يوافق ساطع ابدا على لا على الغاء
الكشافه ولا على استحداث نظام الفتوه ولكن
استحدث بقانون ااه طب يعني انا يعني كانك
تقول استاذي انه نظام الكشافه كانه جيش
احتياط
للتلاميذ لتلاميذ المدارس
تدريبات العسكريه ولا بالجيش في حين نظام
الفتوح هو يشبه بميليشيا همم تدريب للطلبه
همم في الثانويه
همم بوجود همم
عسكريين من وزاره الدفاع وانفق وخصص همم
200,000 دينار عراقي
للشراء اسلحه واشتريت اسلحه همم فنادق
لتدريب الطلبه وبقل الطلب العراقيون حوالي
خمس سنوات همم ضمن هذا النظام الذي يدربهم
الضباط من الجيش العراقي وقد وافق ياسين
الهاشمي رئيس الوزاره على منح
هذا النظام
ضباط من الجيش حتى يدربون
كنت ذكرته في احدى دراساتك في ما يتعلق
بالملك فيصل اا وانه اييي مكان يعني ينجذب
للعنتريه
والاسلوب القوه يعني صحيح انه لديه موقف
من الانتداب البريطاني في ذلك الوقت همم
يفهم جيدا ما هي مصالحهم وكيف تدخلهم في
في العراق يعني استقلال العراق كان
اسميه يعني ليس بشكل تام ام همم لكنه في
نفس الوقت استاذ انه همم سامي شوكت كان
ذكر بان موضوع الصناعه الموت كان عرضها
الملك فيصل قبل وفاته في نفس العام 1933
ويقول هنا ان اغضب هذا القول وزير فرنسا
المفوض في بغداد واحتاج في وقتها لدى
البلاط وكذلك وزاره المعارف التربيه على
كلمه هذه حيث فماسه بالعلاقات الوديه
القائمه بين العراق وفرنسا وعلى اثرها
دعان الملك فيصل الى البلاط الملكي وسلمني
صوره الاحتجاج وقرات الاحتجاج فمتعرضت مما
جاء فيه ولما شاهد الملك فيصل ابتعاضي ربه
على كتفي وقال لا تهتم يا سامي فمضي في
طريقك في ترقين النشء الجديد روح العز
القوميه وحب صناعه الموت
وما من احد يستطيع ان يحل دون تطبيق
مناهجنا هذه على هذه الناشئه اذهب بامان
فشكرته وانصرفت
من قال هذا قال هذا سامي شوكت ولم اجد
لهذا الكلام اي اي
صوره اخرى او اي حادث او يدلي بانه فيصل
وافق على ذلك
الفكره والقانون صدر في عهد غازي وليس في
عهد فيصل
ولا اعتقد ابدا بانه فيصل رحمه الله كان
قد وافق على فكر صناعه الموت ولا على حتى
النظام
المحتمل كان همم
له الفكره كونها موجوده في التراث العربي
القديم منذ العهد العباس نظام
شوكت فلا اظن ذلك ولكن الحادث همم حقيقه
ان ان خطاب سامي شوكت
وبحضور السفير الفرنسي قد اثار مشكله بين
العراق وبين فرنسا همم كونه انتقل فرنسا
وما لقى همم
المانيا وكانت العلاقات ظهرت العلاقات همم
جدا قويه بين العراق والمانيا النازيه في
مرحله او في عهد غازي خليني ادخل معك هنا
في في نقطه همم
حسن البنا بدها تسمح لي الساده حسن البنا
كان همم اسس ما يعرف بالكشافه باسم همم
باسم الجوال همم
الجوالات
هي يعني جوالك مثل الكشافه يعني كانت
شبيهه بشبيبه الهتلريه وهو التنظيم الخاص
بمثابه نواه كان بحسب حسن البنا نوال
الجيش الاسلامي في العام 1940
والقمصان الزرقاء تاسست في 1936
وتشكيل عسكري تابع لحزب الوفد
الالتقاء هنا طبعا انا صراحه
بخصوص همم ما نشرب جريده او مجله الاخوان
المسلمين نذير كان المقال حسن البنا صناعه
الموت هو في عام 1938 لكن وجدت في كتاب
رفعت السيد همم عن حسن البنا كان ذكر في
العام 1934 همم يعني شخصيا اراء ان همم
ممكن ان ارجع ان يكون عام 38 بعد مرور 10
سنوات على تاسيس جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
لانه لم يكن البنا في ذلك الوقت كان يعني
يبغى يظهر بشكل جلي على السطح بهذا
التنظيم الخاص او العسكري فابغى اسالك من
وين جاء التبني الاسلام لنفس هذا العنوان
صناعه الموت
ليس من مكان
همم التاثر كان كبير جدا من قبل
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
كانت تاثير قوي جدا وصولا يعني الى حركه
الرشيد علي الجيلاني بال 41 يقول السادات
بانه نحن كضباط احرار تاثرنا بمنذر شبابنا
الاول
بحركه رشيد عالي في العراق عام 41
باعتبارها ضد الانجليزي اما حسن البنا منذ
1934 بدا يغير من الثوره الاول الذي ظهر
فيه عام 28 همم عندما اسس الجماعه
وبدا يتبنى الافكار التي يطرحها على
العراقيون وخصوصا سامي شوكت في مساله همم
صناعه الموت
وايضا
تاثر العراق باصحاب القمصان الحمر والسود
كان هناك اكثر من تنظيم باسم جمعيه
القمصان الزرق وجمعيه وجمعيه الكف الاصفر
وهناك
اسرار تاريخيه لم تظهر حتى اليوم في مرحله
الثلاثينات وخصوصا بعد رحيل الملك فيصل
الاول عام
التاثر مصر خصوصا بما جرى في العراق عام
العقد الثلاثينات حتى 41 كان كبير جدا
انا ما ادري اذا همم امين الحسيني لان
امين الحسيني كان على اتصال وفيق بمجموعه
القومين في في العراق منهم عزيز علي
المصري وايضا همم
عزيز جزائر العزيز جزائر اما همم
المفتي القدس محمد امين الحسيني
فوصل دوره في العراق
الى ان هو الذي يسير همم الضباط همم
القوميه يعني
وخصوصا العقلاء الاربعه بعد وصوله للعراق
همم
يعني بمنحه من همم من همم رئيس الوزراء
نوري السعيد
والوسع عبد الاله عندما
حليفه همم في بغداد مع جماعته وصل عدد
جماعته الى 500 شخص همم به في الادباء
فيهم النخبه كبيره
وكلهم همم ينقال
ما يقوله المفتي محمد همم محمد امين
الحسيني الذي وثق علاقته القويه بالمانيا
ونعرف ماذا جرى في 41 ال حيث دخل العراق
لوحده العراق دخل لوحده في حرب مع
بريطانيا ابان الحرب العالميه الثانيه
دور محمد امين الحسيني كان قوي جدا في
العراق
قريب جدا من حسن البنا فهل ممكن هو يكون
الحلقه الاتصال ان هذا المصطلح ينتقل من
ثم همم
لم اقع على اي شيء الى حد الان ولكن من
اكبر احتمالات انه كان همم
اعتقد بان العلاقه همم
لا همم مع مع
الفارق القومي الذي ظهرت العراق لانه ما
تقومي قومي جدا ومتسلط ليصل الى حد
الشوفينيه همم وبين
الاتجاه الذي اظهره حسن البنا في مصر وهو
اتجاه اسلامي يختلف اختلافا كبيرا اما كان
يسود في العلم
في في نفسين في التيار القومي في نفس
الالماني الذي كان يجسده ساطع الحصري وفي
الجسد همم اعتذر وفي المكون الثاني اللي
كان يرى العروبه همم يعني لا يوجد حدود
فاصله ما بين العروبه وما بين الاسلام همم
في هذا الاطار فمن هنا كان في تقارب مع
التيار الاسلامي في انا ذاك انا اعتقد انه
ال ال مد القومي في العراق الذي وصل الى
حد التعصب الشوفيني
كله لم يكن هناك فيه نفس همم كل كل نفس
الذي ظهر في مصر
لانه هناك فقط باسم الاخوان المسلمين في
العراق تتبع حسن البنا ههه همم لكن
الاغلبيه يركزون على التراث العربي يعني
القوميون في العراق يركزون على التراث
العربي بما فيهم همم
كانوا علمانيين لكن يركزون على التراث
العربي وحتى سامي شوكت نفسه في العام همم
في عام 46
اظهر قبل ان يظهر من شيء العففله على
الملا
اسس حزبا اسمه سامي شوكت في العراق حزبا
اسمه البحث القومي واصدر جميل باسم البعث
القومي والتقطها ميشيل عقله في دمشق
ونفسي الاسامي شوكت في تاسيس هذا الحزب
لانه رئيس الوزراء فقط
في سوريا
بتاسيسها الحزب الذي تاثر تاثرا كبيرا
بافكار
هو استاذ بالنسبه لموضوع القوميه ومدى
اصطباعها بالعلمانيه والليبراليه او انها
كانت الحدود غير واضحه بين العلمانياتهم
واسلامياتهم واذكر هنا مثال همم كان
قسنطين زريق وهو ارفدكسي القى خطاب في
العام 1938 واكثر مثقفين علمانيين في ذكر
ميلاد النبي محمد عليه الصلاه والسلام
مؤكده انه من اجل النضال القومي نحتاج الى
ان يكون لدينا قاده يستمدون من شخصيه
النبي العربي قوه الايمان والثبات ودعوا
القوميين العرب الى تكريم ذكرى النبي محمد
موحد العرب كان هذا قبل خمس سنوات من خطاب
مشي العفلق الشهير عن ذكر الرسول العربي
انا طبيعي طبيعي قسطنطينيه دوره كبير جدا
جدا في تاسيس ليس فقط الاتجاه القومي انما
الحركات القوميه يعني
الحركات اللي ظهرت بما فيهم الحركه
العربيه
حركه القوميه العرب حزب الباحث العربي
الاشتراكي كل هذه الحركات مصدرها الاساسي
وقسطنطينيه
اساسيا في بيروت
وكان على علاقه قويه بالعراقيين
طب استني الي بنرجع نحنا نتكلم على
الجماعات الاسلامي السياسي
وتبنيها اللي فكره صناعه الموت حتى انها
ساصبحت يعني من عقود وكانها هي هي الجماعه
التي دخلت ارض الجهاد والنضال يعني رغم ان
التيارات القوميه هي من ابتكرت هذا
المصطلح وهذه الجمله فاصبح اليوم كانها هي
همم يعني احدى منتجات الجامعات الاسلام
السياسي مثلا من جمال عبد الله عزام كان
نتبنى ايضا بنفس العباره او بنفس المفهوم
صناعه الموت عشاق الحور الى بلاد في كتابه
كان بتفريغ اللي همم كلها همم محاضرات
وتسجيلات عشاق عشاق الحور الى بلاد
الافراح
فيقول اقبله تمنح لكم عزه الدنيا والاخره
واطلب الموت توهب همم توهب لكم الحياه وان
الامم التي عاشت وسادتها هي الامم التي
تحسن صناعه الموت
فا يعني المفارقه هنا انها كيف انها
جماعات الاسلام السياسي اخذت واقتبسات ااا
وتبنت وانتحلت هذا المفهوم من الجماعات
القوميه
على مدى خمس سنوات من تاسيس الاخوان بعد
1928 لم يكن حسن البنا
يتبنى مثل هذا المفهوم يعني كانت الدعوه
مسالمه في البدايه
ولكن
تاثره بصناعه الموت العراقيه التي اظهرها
سامي شوقي والجماعه
وصول الى 41
واستلهم هذا المصطلح ووجهه تطبيقيا
لكن ما ذلك يبقى يبقى
نفس الاخوان في المرحله الثلاثينات
زاد
التقشير بالعنف ولكن ليس كما ظهر بعد ذلك
على ايدي همم
سيد قطب وجماعته
بطريقه اكثر
ظهر ابي بشكل اكثر باستخدام الاغتيالات
سواء في الاربعينات او الخمسنات
ثم انتقل بعد ذلك الى
العنف العالمي يعني ما سمعته الان عن عبد
الله عزام هذا اصبح
في طور الارهاب يعني
حالا متسلسله متطوره نحو العنف والعنف
الاكثر همم
كيف تطور هذا مفهوم تصدير او صناعه الموت
من همم فكره تمشيريه اولى
مهدها في العراق وصول الى ما حدث
في مصر خصوصا وانتشار ذلك من خلال الاخوان
المسلمين في معظم البلدان العربي
كلها لكن في معظم او اغلب البلدان العربيه
لكن الجماعات اخذت منحا اخر هو منها
الاسلام السياسي وليس منح الاصل اللي هو
القوميه فما
ظهر في القرن العشرين يحتاج همم
ما زال يحتاج الى المزيد من التحليلات
والمقارنه
لان لا يكتفي بدراسه ظاهره في زمنها
المعين عقد معين واحد لكن همم بدا بجذورها
وتاثر تلك الجذور ثم ثم تسلسل سوريا عبر
المكان من زمان لنرى
في نهايه القرن 20 من كراره
بالنسبه يعني احنا مثلا في الفتره
العشرينيه كان هناك تاثر كبير بالمدرسه
الالمانيه في هيام كبير همم المدرسه
الالمانيه
وكان له مبررات انهم اول شيء كانت الدوله
العثمانيه هي يعني
نتكلم عن العثمانيين العرب
العثمانيه الالمانيه القيصريه قويه جدا
يعني بحيث همم
كانت هناك مشاريع فرنسيه وبريطانيا ضد
المانيا من خلال العثمانيين
لقطع الطريق على ايثار او وصول الالمان
الى
الخليج يعني من خلال بناء سكه حديد بي بي
برلين بغداد
وجاءت الحرب العالميه الاولى فالعلاقات مع
المانيا قديمه جدا يعني
منذ
المنتصف القرن التاسع عشر
مع وجود التنظيمات
كانت العلاقات والذي اوصل الدوله
العثمانيه ااه الى الى انهيار حاله
فيها مع المانيا في الحرب العالميه الاولى
ايه يعني احنا يعني هذه موضوع صناعه الموت
هو كان اكتساب من الثقافه التي كانت سائده
في في المانيا والمانيا تحديدا ولا لا
صناعه الموت ولم ياتي تاتي ياتي تعبير
صناعه الموت مثلا همم الشهاده يعني كان
يكون
طريق الشهاده لا عنوان اصر سامي شوكت عليه
هو صناعه الموت ايش كان بالضبط يقصده في
خصم من كتابه هذه مفاهيمنا فمن امن بها
فهو منا او معنا
خطابات هو
ليس مؤلفه بالذات لكن هي خطابات او مقالات
جمعها في
مثلا همم هو يبحث عن شرف الامم يعني همم
ليس هناك اهم من المال والعلم شرف الامم
ويحول همم دون الذل والاستعمال ما هو انه
يكون هناك صناعه للشباب همم
يذهبوا يذهبون بدمائهم يصنعون الموت
بانفسهم لكي يحققون شرفهم او شرف الامه
هذه الفكره الاساسيه يعني حتى لو كان
صناعه الموت بالحديد والنار اقرها سامي
شوكت يعني همم دون الموت تحت سنابك كما
يقول الخيول وهمم
همم
تحت احذيه الجندي الاجنبي وما شابه ذلك
يعني لم لا اي طريق لا يعرف المفاوضات ولا
يعرف طريقه للسلم لكن هو في عقليته ان
الامم لا يمكن ان تحافظ على شرفها الا من
خلال الموت او صناعه الموت والموت لا
يعرفه الشباب الا ان كان الا ان كانت
الدوله
تصنعه لهم وهذا ما يعني على مدى تاريخ
طويل في القرن العشرين والى حد الان في
العراق همم الموت رخيص يعني جدا مع الاسف
ااه
لانهم لا يتبعون طريقا غير هذا الطريق
هو بالنسبه له لصناعه الموت هل هي
الاغتيالات هل هي همم يعني ميليشيا تقويم
ميليشيات الشل يعني حتى نوع العمليات مثلا
يدرب الشباب على الموت
يلقنهم طريق الشهاده ايه يعلمهم كيف
يتدربون لكي يذهبوا الى سوق حلوه
لا سبيل امام اي بلد مستعبد الا صناعه
الموت هذه فكرته يعني هو يستخدم الطريقه
همم
بتبرير مثالي جدا همم ولكن بثمن غالي يعني
ثمن شيء يعني هو ادمن شيء يملكه الانسان
صحيح
يقول الحي اذا كانت الحياه حق
فالموت ايضا
بالنسبه لسامي شوكت كان حدث يعني كان في
خصومه شديده بيني وبين الاحزاب الوطنيه
تيارات الوطنيه وقتها
ابرزها كانت الحزب الوطني الديمقراطي ابو
التيارات اليساريه ابغى بس اذكر شيء هنا
كان ذكر الاديب علي جواد الطاهر وطبعا هو
الملقب بشيخ النقاد عن اراء سامي شوكت همم
يتحدث بالم وسخريه وقال ننتهي من الفتوه
من عمل كان ماضيه للوقت منذ ثلاث سنوات
استجابه لراي متمكن لسعاده مدير المعارف
العامه
اهدافنا من امن بها فهو منا ورافعات شوينه
فان الترف يزيل النعم ينشر في مدارس من
الفقر المدقه
لم تعرف للشعار معنا ويعود الى الشعار
العسكري في موضع اخر ساخر بعد ان راى راي
العين الوضع المجري للمدرسه القرويه التي
عين فيها في همم في 1940 فتضحك ضحكا مرا
سوري طبعا همم علي جواهر بيرجع يعني
بيسخر من وضع المدرسه اللي كان همم
تمتعينه فيها ووضعها السير فيقول فتضحك
ضاحكا مرا وتفضل لاول مره انه
بديلا لخشوشينه ان سعاده المدير العام
المناعم في بغداد لم يخرج يوما ليرى ما
عليه قومه من ضنك وخشونه تعيش وشغله شاغل
والشغل وهو شاغل من الترف الذي هو فيه
واعلان يكرره ان هذه اهدافنا فما اهدافك
يا صاحب السعاده ان لم تكن مطلعا على
معانات قومك
ايش رايك في حديثه في هذا الجمله الساخره
يعني بدل يعني انه شاف ان يطالب الناس بان
يخشو شنو هم بالاساس ليست لهم مقومات وشوك
طبيعه الخلاف لو باجاز مع التيارات
اليسريه ذاك الوقت
لكن
توفي عام 19
875 94 لكن من خلال
زمن طويل انا اراقب احوالها هؤلاء
المثقفين وقد كتبته عنهم في كتاب انت
الجنس الى العراق تاريخ اللغه العراقيه
وجدتهم يعني سامي شوكت كان له انصاره ايضا
ليس هناك كل اليسار ضده همم
قراره هذا بالفتوه لان فتوه هي تدري يعني
رامي الفتوه كما سالت اكثر من
ذهب راحلا يعني اا سالتهم عن هذا النظام
قال هو نظام تدريبي يعني في فترات محدده
يدربون على السلاح
انه الشباب
لكن لم يجري على الارض قتال بحيث صنعوا
الموت بانفسهم بعدين سامي شوكت
الخلاف الاساسي ضده كان طبقيا لانه هو من
سبيل العائله من الحكام المماليك في في
بغداد منذ القرن الثامن عشر
الاستقراطيه لكن هؤلاء ضده ليس من
ضد فكره افكاري
لكن ضد طبقي طبقي طبقيته همم
لا يستطيع سامي الشوكاني
كل المدارس همم
هنا همم الدارس يجب ان يكون موضوعيا في ان
لا ينكل بطرف على حساب طرف اخر وان يتحرر
الحقيقه في دراسته مثل هذه المواضيع
الحساسه وهي كثر يعني المواضيع في العراق
مثل هذه ليست واحده هي كثيره جدا همم
سامي شوكت باعلامي هذا مثلا انا لست معه
لست معه صناعه هذا الموت
مساء الاخرى
همم عندما يتحكم عقل
الانسانه بمثل هذه الطريقه همم
خسر كثير
ولم يتفق معه الجميع يعني الحكومات اغلبها
لم ترتفع معه لكن وفتره الزياره الى 41
بعد 41 بشتغل سياسه ولكنه لم يوافق علما
بان اخوه الاكبر ناجي شوكت رئيس وزاره
سفير العراق المشهور في تركيا
وحتى سامي
كثيره في الجمعيات الطبيه وساهمه كثيرا في
كليه
طب وكالقى مو له اييي
مشاريع خيريه منها التدرن منها
فالرجل يعني عندما نكون منصفين يجب ان
ينتقد فكرته ولكن لا ننتقد سامي شوكت
طب
في بعض من بيشوف انه مفهوم صناعه الموت
اللي وضع اسامي شوكت كان من ابلغ وابكر
النصوص العربيه في التعبير الرومانسيقي او
الرومانسي العنيف والاراده همم والاعمى عن
كل واقع همم وان همم رغم ان هذا المفهوم
لم يعني لم يغب عنه البعد الالماني بهذا
الشكل فهل هل تتفق مع هذا انه همم يعني
همم
تجديد مبكر
العنف
الرومنطيقي مثلا
هو الفكره الفكره كلها رومانسي
الشعوب
التعبير
يعني
الانسان همم
ان يكون هناك تنظيم يتبنى مثل هذه الصناعه
همم
ولا استطيع ان اقول كلها علمانيه لانه حتى
الالمانيين من ضمنهم سامي
التراث الاسلامي استخدم الايه القرانيه
استخدم الانسان وسيله لتبرير فكرته
هي مرحله مرحله سادت فيها
مثل هذه الافكار ليس فقط في العراق وانما
اوروبا
كما نعلم والاحتي كانت نتيجهها الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
وبعد الحرب انتهى انتهت مثل هذه
الايدلوجيات نهائيا
[موسيقى]
كان الاستاذ حازم صغير في كتابه رومانسي
في هذا المعنى الذي يكون من المبالغه وصف
تنظيم الدوله او داعش بوصفه التتويج
والخلاص المنطقيه للانسلاخ عن الواقع
الراهن وتاليا لاكثر اشكال الرومنطيقيه
راديكاليه ووحشيه وابتدالا في ان معا اام
بحسب هذا التوصيف ما ادري الى اي ماده انا
ممكن نعتبر بغدادي داعش وقبل الزرقاء
الجليات الرومانسيه في العصر الحديث
ما هو انا وصفت ما سبق الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
هذه الاتجاهات الرومانسيه حتى ولو كانت
عنيفه
وما قبل الحرب العالميه الثانيه كان
الاكثر رومانسيه في ولايه الاتجاهات جديده
ايضا تخاطب اللاواقع يعني
تبث شعارات لا يمكن تحقيقها ابدا
لكن ما جرى بعد ذلك على يد الاسلام
السياسي بالذات
اعتبره ثالثه وليس وليس امرا رومانسيه
لانه اذا كان ذلك مقتصرا على اتجاهات
سياسيه
فهنا فهنا قد اوغل المجتمع كله
ليست فقط التيارات السياسيه كل المجتمع
يريده ان يذوب في مثل هذا الجحيم او بمثل
اوصول الى هذه اذا اخذناها من منطلق
المفاهيم اللي يتبناها الاسلام السياسي
اللي هي اليوتيوب يعني
الخلافه
الحكم
بما انزل الله يعني عرفت المبادئ حقتهم
المثاليه هذه بعض بيشوفها متقاربه مع نفس
المبادئ اللي حملها القوميين العرب بانها
من امه واحده امه عربيه من المحيط الى
الخليج بنفس الاطار
ليس تختلف تماما يعني هو المد القومي الذي
ظهر منذ الثلاثينات وصولا الى 79 يعني انا
نشرت ذلك 79 هي ال ال الحد الفاصل ما بين
ما تقومي ساده هو عده اتجاهات قوميه
وبين مد الاسلام السياسي لان الاسلام
السياسي كان يمثله الاخوان
وحزب التحرير
الاسلام لكن بعد ال 79 وهي اخطر سنه ظهرت
في القرن العشرين اخطر سنه هي
1979 بدخول السوفيت الى افغانستان
الحرب معها
اصول تاسيس نظام الخميني
باسم الجمهوريه الاسلاميه 9 بخصوص صدام
حسين السلطه
جهيمان في في المملكه
كلها بالتسعه وسبعين
انساقط الى حاله اخرى الى الى
ظاهره جديده اووو
اصبحت الحركات القوميه والتاريخ القومي
كله هو وراء الستار
تختلف تختلف
التموجات
الاسلاميه العنيفه التي ظهر بعد 79 وولاده
التنظيمات الكثيره جدا الاسلاميه ان ال ال
الاتجاهات القوميه التي ظهرت
في بعض
المختصين في
شان مثلا الجماعات الاسلاميه او
الباحثين في هذا الاطار بيرعوا ان العام
79 هو تجليات لكن يعني وصول الخميني وجه
ايمان وهمم الحرب يعني المقاتلين افغان
العرب يعني الذهاب اللي همم للمشاركه في
القتال هناك لكن قبلها كان في في زخم في
منطقه في كل المنطقه يعني تلك التصور بان
هناك همم يعني في همم انتعاش اللي مثل هذه
التيارات الاسلاميه الراديكالي وهذا الفكر
الاصولي همم اذا تسمح لي دكتور بدي اختم
معك في هذا السؤال
الباب بيشوف ان التيارات اليساريه كانت
تعيب على
التيارات القوميه او من يحملون الفكره
القوميه همم بانه لديهم مثل همم لوث
مثاليه من حيث اللغه والثقافه
وكان هذا يعني منزلاق لدى اليسار بانه
بانتقاس من جانب اللغه والثقافه والتكوين
النفسي والشعور القومي همم يعني باعتبار
انها معبره يعني همم عن موقف مثالي يعني
مش واقعي همم فليستطيع اليسار استيعاب
المساله قوميه
ليس في كل المناطق يعني هو الصراع القومي
الاممي معروف بين
اليسار وخصوصا الشيوعيين وبين القوميين
وخصوصا في منطقه العربيه
لكن اييي اييي هناك مناطق لا
موجود فيها
موجوده الناس على القوميه عند اغلب
الاسعار والمارسيين همم لكن تجلى الصراع
بين اليسار وبين القوميين في العراق ايضا
همم
وخصوصا بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ووصل الى حد الصراعات الدمويه في الشوارع
في اي مكان
فلا استطيع ان اقول ان
هناك تلاقي اصلا في الفكره بين القوميين
وبين اليسار
علما بان القوميين اخذوا من اليسار الكثير
والدعوا بان هناك يسار
اعاده ما يعني بيرى ان ال- ال- الاحزاب
القوميه او القوميين دائما ما يصفها بانها
سوفانيه وانها همم يعني همم
يعني لديها عنصريه همم فهل هذا صحيح ينطبق
على كل
الاراء القوميه في همم ينطبق عليها انها
تكون كلها فاشيه
يعني
يعني هناك
العديد من القوميين كانوا اييي ناس
طبيعيين يعني صح يعني ساطع مثلا لم يكن
اييي صح كان عنيدا كان
مؤمنا بالقوميه العربيه ولكن
ليس
متكلسا
ذاهبا في طريق اللاعب بالعكس السفاره
المعارف العراقيه او مؤسسه
[موسيقى]
رئيس دائره ثقافه في الجامعه
لكن
بالنسبه للفرق الاساسي في التفكير القومي
واليساري انه التفكير اليسار هو اممي
والتفكير القومي هو قومي
في في كان بعض القوميين من يعني ينتقد
التيار اليسار فيقول لان انتم تبنيتم شعار
يا عمال الارض اتحدوا فكيف تكونوا يعني
امميين ويعني تستنقص من ان يكون هناك بعد
قومي لدى
العرب
لم لم افهم طبيعه السؤال علما بان همم
اغلب الاحزاب القوميه التي اطلقت على
نفسها كدوريه
تامين وتجارب عديده اخذتها من اليسار ليس
من من عندي يعني
لكن اليسار لكن اليسار
لا يؤمن بي ان هناك قوميه عربيه او يمكن
ان تؤسس عليها دوله واحده من المحيطه
الخليج يعني ممكن
طرحات المعروفه يعني في اكثر من مكانه
يمكن ان نتحد كونفدراليه يعني تبقى الدول
شكرا جزيلا دكتور شكرا
وهكذا تنتهي حلقتنا اعزائي المستمعين
والمشاهدين مع الدكتور سيار جميل الذي
تحدثنا مع عن مفهوم صناعه الموتور
وفي الجزء الثاني باذن الله بنكمل حديثنا
عن
سامي شوكت ونحاول نعرف فيه وابرزت الاحزاب
التي انشاها وطبيعه علاقه بالتيارات التي
كانت في العراق انا ذاك هذا جماعات وانا
هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]